what's going on reject nation Greg out
here so I'm about to watch the defenders
Punisher reveal trailer I don't know
what this is exactly and pretty sure is
released from comic-con I'm kind of a
sense I kind of find my punisher shirts
i have two of them and I look for 20
minutes but find just one of them to
wear I got to give a heads up I'm going
to be going out of town for the weekend
the defenders comes out and going to a
wedding in Colorado so I won't actually
be around to watch the defenders opening
weekend which is a bummer I wanted one
of them like my most anticipated show
this entire year so I'm kind of bummed
that I won't be able to be here opening
weekend to watch it but I'm going to be
out of town and I don't want to be the
guy who spend the whole time while he's
out in Colorado watching the defenders I
wanted just have like 2/9 rights watch
the whole thing let's check it out
they're the greatest stories ever told
and they are heroes showing that money
don't we to be perfect to do what's
right
well they have an advantage not about
living without fear but facing injustice
it's not about being powerful but wrong
in your calling when you least expect it
they show us it's okay to be vulnerable
[Music]
because even though the hero is still
human that they are
[Music]
respond assure those I gave you just
boom that's it ah ah man I wanted more
looks like I got wait a minute does that
mean I thought he wasn't going to be in
the defenders show I know he's doing the
solo show but is he does that means
actually gonna be in the defenders that
would be cool make it that much better
that is exciting tease man I really hope
Frank castles in the defenders show I
liked having Stan Lee inside of New York
City and showing that oh he was around
too you know all the theories about who
is Stan Lee's character that Kevin Feige
was talking about after gardens of
galaxy vol 2 it's like showing that they
could have had like a Stan Lee cameo
inside of the shows as well I know the
Marvel movie studios don't really care
as much to promote or do all their major
tie-ins with the ABC shows or the
Netflix series but I thought it was cool
that Stan Lee would lend his his face
and his voice to the defenders coming up
because people really loved this show
I'm a huge fan and I prefer the Netflix
shows over the movies actually excluding
Iron Fist and that damn chefs was only
one atom one out of four shows and I
liked what he was saying too about how
our heroes are human and while that's a
theme that is also in a lot of the
big-budget major blockbuster ones it's
definitely more present and more
prevalent inside the defenders show so I
thought it was cool that Stan Lee was
talking about that that's one of my
favorite things about the Netflix shows
is they feel the most human the most
relatable the most grounded so I really
appreciate Stan Lee driving around New
York City and seeing all these events
going on I kind of know Stanley will
make an actual cameo in the defenders
show that would be really cool I know
the defenders panel it's happening on
Friday I'm hoping we get another trailer
for it I'm hoping we get a Punisher
trailer that I'm super excited to see
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell and
check out our exclusive personal rewards
over at patreon.com slash the real
rejects would love to have you part of
that community that's growing over there
love you one Mitch